je trouve que les résultats de l'étude
sont vraiment intéressants aujourd'hui
camille et michael sont des employés de
l'hôpital sainte justine où leur vie a
commencé à l'unité de néonatalogie au
tournant des années 90 j'ai 27 ans je
finissais à sainte justine à 26 semaines
de gestation
je n'ai à 25 semaines et j'ai maintenant
28 ans c'était tout naturel pour eux
d'être parmi la centaine de jeunes
adultes que suit le centre de recherche
de l'hôpital
ils sont ce qu'on appelle des grands
prématurés nés avant 29 semaines de
grossesse selon enfance les parents ont
fermement attention on ne re
développement est ce que mon enfant
marche au bon moment tout manger marcher
un peu tard
l'équipe de chercheurs qui publient leur
étude dans la dernière édition de la
revue high potential révèle que les
prématurés de 29 semaines et moins ont
deux à trois fois plus de risques de
faire de l'hypertension artérielle
qu'ils ont deux fois plus de risques de
présenter une intolérance au glucose
menant au diabète et que les risques d'
obstruction pulmonaires sont trois fois
et demi plus élevés pour eux quand dans
la hotte prescience c'est silencieux
quand un intolérant au glucose c'est
silencieux aussi sauf que si on le
mesure on peut le détecter
c'est important ce moment-là
d'intervenir précocement pour changer un
peu sa trajectoire lot de risques de
maladies chroniques des risques qu'on
associe plus naturellement à l'obésité
par exemple elle est prématurée
e on se laisse jamais ne sont pas
nécessairement aux balles mais sont
quand même à risque
ses premières conclusions sont donc
utiles pour dépister et aussi prévenir
les problèmes cardiovasculaires
notamment par l'exercice
un conte respiratoires plutôt exemple
l'éducation physique cela tout en étant
peut-être un petit peu plus difficile
mais je fais des jeux fin des 10 km pour
le plaisir puis réussit très bien à le
faire de bout en bout
toute ma vie on me dit à camatte battu
les statistiques d un miracle donc ont
un grand sentiment d'invincibilité temps
on n'a pas l'impression que
il y aura encore des choses qui
pouvaient qui pourrait arriver dû à la
prématurité 10 % des naissances sont
prématurées un de ses bébés sur 10 mais
sans avant 29 semaines
le taux de survie de ces derniers est
passé de 65 à 90 % aujourd'hui
ici anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal